[Música]
bolivia es el único país del mundo donde
la popular cadena de hamburguesas
mcdonald's sin lugar a dudas uno de los
símbolos de la globalización ha quebrado
tras poco más de cinco años de
operaciones sus ocho restaurantes en el
país tuvieron que cerrar sus puertas en
2002 porque simplemente los bolivianos
pasaron de ellos
[Música]
vamos que casi podemos decir que para
muchos hoy bolivia es algo así como la
aldea de astérix y obélix un rincón del
mundo que se resiste contra viento y
marea a lo que esta misma gente llama el
imperialismo cultural de la
globalización y las grandes potencias
occidentales precisamente el presidente
boliviano evo morales un gran exponente
de esta forma de pensar su hostilidad
hacia todo lo que tiene que ver con el
capitalismo alcanza tan nivel ojo que se
jacta de llevar más de cinco años sin
tomar un solo vaso de coca colá compra
cocacola y echa a la taza del baño pasan
minutos y ya está destapada la tasa del
daño pero bueno más allá amigos de este
tipo de historias anecdóticas lo cierto
es que el discurso de evo morales es uno
de los más beligerantes contra el libre
mercado la globalización y los sistemas
políticos occidentales
es vivir bien suso el buen vivir como
dice nuestro hermano presidente de
ecuador
es la síntesis del
socio a nivel comunitario
vivir mejor es la síntesis del
capitalismo es hay una profunda
diferencia de hecho a día de hoy casi
podemos decir que evo es el último líder
de ese ciclo de izquierdas que dio
comienzo a principios del siglo 21 y que
hasta hace muy poquito ha dominado la
política latinoamericana me refiero a
líderes como hugo chávez y maduro en
venezuela- kirchner en argentina lula y
dilma en brasil o por supuesto rafael
correa en ecuador
[Música]
de todos ellos a día de hoy sólo
sobreviven liderando la política y
nacional de sus países evo morales y
nicolás maduró claro que en
circunstancias muy diferentes mientras
en venezuela el desastre es
prácticamente total el país casi ha
quebrado bolivia ha sido durante los
últimos tres años el país que más ha
crecido de toda latinoamérica
[Música]
esto ha hecho que llevo prácticamente
conserve intacta sus altísimas cotas de
popularidad y reconocimiento
internacional al tiempo que para muchos
seguramente también muchos de vosotros
se ha convertido en el gran referente de
la izquierda que en sus propias palabras
aspira a terminar con la globalización
imperialista dominada por las grandes
multinacionales el resultado es que para
muchos empezando por el mismo evo
morales- de su líder indiscutible un
ejemplo a seguir antes los políticos
iban a estudiar a harvard en eeuu en
lovaina en bélgica ahora vienen a
estudiar nuestras políticas y se las
llevan para otros en cambio no es más
que un líder populista que está
cercenando las libertades civiles y
conduciendo a su país al desastre pero
cuál es la verdad cómo está realmente
bolivia ha logrado de verdad evo
morales- el boom económico que se le
atribuye estas son algunas de las
preguntas a las que vamos a contestar en
este vídeo pero antes de nada echemos un
vistazo atrás a la historia para que
veamos dónde comenzó todo
la gran crisis boliviana y las reformas
bolivia amigos es un país increíblemente
rico en recursos naturales oro plata
estaño y hierro gas natural petróleo e
incluso litio muchísimo litio y ojo
porque este es uno de los recursos
naturales más cotizados en nuestros días
habéis oído hablar del salar de uyuni es
impresionante océano de color blanco que
atrae a gente de todo el mundo en busca
de una foto perfecta casi propia de otro
planeta pues bien tras esa brillante
capa de sal que cubre su superficie se
encuentra una de las mayores reservas de
litio del mundo para que os hagáis una
idea a día de hoy las reservas estimadas
de litio de bolivia tendrían un valor de
mercado de cerca de 80.000 millones de
dólares casi tres veces todo el pib del
país y a todo ello hay que sumar el
resto gas petróleo oro vamos un
despliegue impresionante de riquezas
como dicen también en perú este país
está sentado sobre un trono de oro a
pesar de ello amigos de visual polític
bolivia es hoy y ha sido
tradicionalmente uno de los países más
pobres de toda latinoamérica fijaros a
inicios del siglo 21 prácticamente antes
de ayer el ingreso por habitante de
bolivia era similar al de la república
democrática del congo con todo podemos
decir que los 80 fueron la década más
dolorosa tras unos convulsos años 70
dominados por continuos golpes de estado
y regímenes militares que endeudaron al
país hasta las cejas y destruyeron
prácticamente cualquier actividad
productiva la caída del precio del
estaño que por aquel entonces era la
mayor exportación del país hundió a
bolivia en una crisis brutal
hola
por si fuese poco la respuesta del
gobierno de izquierdas de la unión
democrática y popular que lideró el
presidente hernán siles suazo fue tan
mala que el país cayó en una
hiperinflación
descomunal de más del 25 mil por ciento
en apenas unos años y retrocedió atentos
30 años en términos de desarrollo baste
mencionar que cuantos ileso ha subido al
poder se pagaban 230 pesos por dólares
cuando terminó su gobierno se pagaba un
millón 149 mil 354 pesos por cada ojo
hasta 2008 bolivia no recuperó la renta
media que tenía en
1977 ante este desolador panorama el
gobierno convocó en 1985 apenas dos años
y medio después de tomar el poder y
elecciones que esta vez llevaron a la
presidencia a víctor paz estenssoro que
ya había sido presidente en tres
ocasiones anteriores primera tarea que
va a emprender el nuevo gobierno es
poner freno al proceso de crisis que
está viviendo el país vamos a
enfrentarnos a la crisis
desde ese momento y durante
prácticamente toda la década de los 90
los diferentes gobiernos bolivianos y
sobre todo el encabezado por el
presidente sánchez de lozada pusieron en
marcha reformas muy importantes
impulsadas por cierto por el fondo
monetario internacional y el banco
mundial que perseguían estas reformas
pues fundamentalmente amigos dotar a
bolivia de una economía competitiva de
mercado
[Música]
así que en estos años se sucedieron las
privatizaciones se liberalizaron
muchísimos aspectos de la economía se
trató de combatir el déficit fiscal se
redujeron los aranceles el estado en su
nuevo rol será excluido de las labores
productivas y de la inversión financiera
directa concentrándose en crear las
condiciones para permitir el
funcionamiento de los mercados suena
bonito verdad el problema es que las
reformas no consiguieron superar ni la
corrupción ni el capitalismo de
amiguetes es verdad que se lograron
muchos avances la economía se estabilizó
y crece una media del 4 por ciento
durante todos los años 90 pero claro
esto era insuficiente para sacar al país
de la pobreza
y luego era un crecimiento muy inferior
al que registraban muchos países
emergentes por ejemplo en asia sin
seguridad jurídica y sin competencia
poco había que hacer es decir me explico
no es que los planteamientos fuesen
erróneos ni muchísimo menos el problema
fue que la implantación que la puesta en
marcha de estas reformas fue simplemente
horrible por supuesto como ocurre casi
siempre cuando se reforma algo tiene un
coste social por ejemplo muchos mineros
y campesinos minifundistas perdieron su
trabajo y se vieron obligados a emigrar
a las ciudades
[Música]
pero claro la falta de resultados
visibles generó muchísima frustración
social por así decirlo hubo muchas
promesas y pocos resultados y tal vez os
preguntéis cuál fue la gota que colmó el
vaso pues en este caso no fue
responsabilidad de bolivia sino de sus
vecinos las crisis de brasil y
argentina- de principios del siglo
acabaron por derrumbar cualquier signo
de prosperidad el país exportaba a estos
países y como éstos estaban pasando una
crisis brutal bolivia no se quedó atrás
entre 1999 y 2003 la economía boliviana
no creció nada
[Música]
un país tan pobre incapaz de crecer algo
falla verdad el modelo no puede ser
bueno
el movimiento cocalero y el movimiento
indígena bolivia ha sido siempre tal vez
muchos lo sepáis un gran productor de
planta de coca que tradicionalmente los
países andinos se utiliza como goma de
mascar y también para hacer infusiones
sin embargo esta planta también tiene un
uso digamos mucho más lucrativo la
producción de cocaína la droga ilegal
que más dinero mueve de todo el mundo
pues bien en los años 80 y 90 y eeuu ya
se encontraba en plena guerra contra las
drogas impresionaba y pagaba a los
gobiernos latinoamericanos para que
destruyeran los cultivos el problema es
que esto implicaba dejar sin trabajo y
arruinar a decenas de miles de familias
[Música]
eso es precisamente lo que ocurrió en
bolivia muchos campesinos vieron cómo el
gobierno iniciaba una guerra contra los
productores cocaleros y destruía sus
plantaciones así que ya os podéis
imaginar el cabreo monumental de esta
población
[Música]
qué es tener un negocio que generaba
mucho dinero solo en 1986 las ventas de
cocaína igualaban a todas las
exportaciones legales del país desde
luego los campesinos cocaleros no se
quedaron de brazos cruzados se agruparon
en sindicatos y recurrieron a una
continua movilización manifestaciones
cortes de carretera bloqueos pero esto
no es todo aún hay más en bolivia la
población de origen indígena que es casi
la mitad del total estuvo
tradicionalmente excluida del poder
político es decir de facto boliviano un
país muy racista pero no con una minoría
sino contra la mayoría de su población
de locos
[Música]
bien así que ya tenemos los tres
factores claves que impulsaron al más al
movimiento al socialismo el partido al
cual pertenece ivonne morales que por
cierto era el instrumento político que
desarrollaron los sindicalistas
campesinos los representantes cocaleros
fundamentalmente crisis y frustración
económica guerra contra la coca y
racismo precisamente estos fueron los
pilares de un partido el más que arrasó
en las elecciones de 2005 obteniendo una
inédita mayoría absoluta que no sólo
mantuvo sino que incluso incrementó en
2009 y en 2014
[Música]
los resultados de cebos morales
la primera gran medida de evo fue
nacionalizar el sector de los
hidrocarburos y lo hizo además a lo
grande ordenando al ejército ocupar los
yacimientos de gas aunque lo cierto casi
siempre hay una historia entre
bastidores es que más allá de las fotos
lo que se hizo no fue sino renegociar
los contratos de explotación conforme a
una ley que ya estaba aprobada antes de
la llegada de eeuu pero bueno el caso es
que el gobierno boliviano con las
reformas multiplicó la renta petrolera
es decir lo que recauda con la
explotación del petróleo y el gas
natural el gobierno pasó de llevarse
algo menos de un 20 por ciento a más del
80 por ciento de los ingresos justo
además en un momento ni que daba
comienzo el llamado super ciclo de las
materias primas y los hidrocarburos que
multiplicaron sus precios
[Música]
y esto es todo por si fuese poco en 2005
poco antes de la llegada de evo al poder
tanto el banco mundial como el fondo
monetario internacional decidieron
condonar la deuda externa que bolivia
tenía contraída con ellos de un plumazo
el país se liberó del 35 por ciento de
toda la deuda exterior y claro estos dos
factores fueron auténtica gasolina para
los gobiernos de evo morales que
contaron con recursos públicos como
nunca antes había tenido el gobierno de
bolivia en cierto modo esto explica la
evolución tan positiva que ha tenido la
economía boliviana durante estos años
pero
ojo es verdad que el gobierno de evo
morales ha hecho cosas relativamente
bien por ejemplo de todos los gobiernos
de izquierdas en latinoamérica que antes
hemos mencionado ha sido el más prudente
a la hora de gastar de hecho ha reducido
la deuda pública y ha acumulado ahorros
importantes también ha apostado mucho
por la inversión en un país que
prácticamente carecía de toda la
infraestructura y ha contribuido
enormemente a la cohesión social con la
integración de los pueblos indígenas
bueno
pero un momento antes de cosa balance
sobre mi espera porque la historia no ha
acabado aquí una cosa es que haya hecho
las cosas mejor que los gobiernos de
chávez maduro correa o kirchner y otra
muy distinta es que las cosas se hayan
hecho bien es verdad que desde que está
en el poder el país ha crecido una media
del 5% cada año y que la pobreza se ha
reducido a la mitad pero claro es que
cuando los precios del petróleo y las
materias primas cayeron empezaron los
problemas el país es más dependiente de
los recursos naturales que cuando evo
morales llegó al poder y eso desde luego
no es algo positivo de hecho hoy en
bolivia las importaciones son mayores
que las exportaciones el déficit público
real del gobierno en 2016 pudo superar
la friolera del 8% la inversión privada
es muy muy reducida y según el doing
bussiness es uno de los países de todo
el mundo donde más difícil resulta hacer
negocios
fijaros en nueva zelanda un país que ya
sabéis que nos encanta solo se requiere
un trámite para iniciar un negocio y se
tarda medio día en hacerlo el coste es
ridículo en bolivia en cambio son
necesarios 50 días 15 trámites y ojos 7
meses de los ingresos promedios de
montar una empresa de verdad alguien aún
piensa que haciendo tan complicado
montar empresas y negocios un país puede
prosperar nuestros antepasados a quien
llevan aquí no conocieron la pobreza la
pobreza es producto de la colonización y
de los modelos de desarrollo económico y
social implantado por los países
capitalistas y luego está también el
problema del narcotráfico
[Música]
y ojo que nadie se lleve a engaño
bolivia sigue siendo hoy uno de los tres
países más pobres de sudamérica tal vez
todo esto junto a la aparición de
sospechas de corrupción ciertas promesas
incumplidas la poca confianza en la
justicia que ha promovido y algunos
gestos como éste el enorme ego de evo
morales inaugura un museo sobre su vida
propiciaron la primera gran derrota del
más en 2016 en febrero se llevó a cabo
en bolivia un referéndum que tenía por
objetivo cambiar la constitución para
permitir que evo se presentase a un
tercer mandato consecutivo y ganó el no
aún así parece que vos sigue empeñado la
elección de evo morales vuelve a
polarizar bolivia bueno tú qué piensas
cuál es tu opinión sobre el gobierno de
evo morales crees que llevó a qatar a la
constitución y se marchará a su casa o
tratará de aferrarse al poder espero que
este vídeo te haya resultado interesante
si ha sido así y quieres que hablemos
más de bolivia de evo morales y de otros
políticos latinoamericanos no te olvides
en darle al botón de like para hacernos
y por supuesto si aún no lo has hecho
suscríbete al canal un saludo y hasta la
próxima amigos compra cocacola y echa a
la taza del baño pasan minutos y ya está
destapada la taza del baño
[Música]